[Music]
rusty is in odessa texas hey rusty
what's up
hey guys how are you great man how can
we help
you're doing well hey i've been
following your plan for about 20 years
we're on baby step 7. i wanted to ask
you a question about something that
we're starting to see
is places that are no longer taking cash
or basically penalizing those of us that
are using cash like
entertainment places where you have to
put cash on a on a play card um and then
if you don't use all of it you don't get
it all back which is curious your
thoughts about that
not familiar with that type of
transaction um
uh
you know i mean obviously there's
situations where i just look as a matter
of principle i choose not to do business
with somebody
by the way by the they are putting forth
barriers to me
they're requiring things of me as a
customer
uh maybe around covid or around cash or
something that i don't want to do and
therefore i don't do it and that means i
can't be their customer and that's okay
they own the business they're allowed to
say that
um
as far as i know the whole legal tender
thing
won't work i mean they're supposed to
accept legal tender that's the whole
purpose of a currency but i don't know
of anyone enforcing that
at the federal level which is what it
would have to be i guess so i think
that's probably more of a philosophical
discussion than anything else but i
carry a debit card so if i'm in a
situation like that um unless the people
are just being weird or something i i i
use a debit card to run a tab at a place
or something if i need to but i'm not
going to give somebody cash it's
non-refundable if i don't use it all
right what is that like a club like a
nightclub thing yeah it's like a it's uh
like an entertainment that has like
movies and bowling alleys and game rooms
and things like that oh yeah it's like a
dave and buster's type thing or
something or a chucky cheese exactly
right yeah okay
all right yeah i'm not uh no i mean that
will they take a debit card
they will but i like to use my cash okay
well i don't blame you there i mean i
don't blame you but so it comes down to
you know a
horrible transaction which is the plate
thing you were describing i'm not doing
that for sure uh or i like to use my
cash and you people are making this
difficult and so you're basically saying
i don't want you as a customer rusty and
you say okay then i won't be your
customer i'll go
i'll go bowling somewhere else you know
and so there you go i'll look for my
excitement elsewhere
or you can use if it's something you're
you're not uh wanting to take a stand on
you know it's not i mean i don't make a
principled
uh
uh picketing uh stand on every single
transaction i do i just look at it and
go you know this one's not worth it i'm
not fighting this one or this one i'm
gonna fight and i'm not gonna do this
and so
you know i uh um
you know i i uh so anyway you just got
to decide that and and say
uh
i'm not going there but you're right
there's more and more places that have
gone to
cashless i was in a uh
a breakfast place
a tiny little meat and three breakfast
place off the side of the beaten path up
off of uh
outside of aspen colorado last year
and um they didn't take cash
and i was like god i'm i mean it was
like a biscuits and gravy kind of thing
it wasn't like it wasn't like some kind
of froofroo thing or something you know
yeah and uh i i went in there and i was
like god
i just wonder i didn't leave my debit
card like back at the hotel or something
i would have to go back and get that
yeah or you know what the reason is keep
my what in their case
they were doing it uh because they were
well it's aspen i mean they're just
they're frou-frou right so the food
wasn't fruit fruit but they have the
little thing come to the table and you
know and check you out with this
high-tech thing at the table
the biscuits weren't high-tech but the
payment methodology was high-tech
they're paying for that and so yeah they
are and like three percent every time
you swipe for yourself for biscuits i'd
take a dollar but um but that's you know
so anyway i was just i had a pocket full
of cash i always do but yeah thank
goodness i had a debit card because
sharon would probably still be there
washing dishes but
i would love to see it instagram from
dave ramsey i'm just like and i stopped
paying for my meal dave's in the back
washing dishes
and then they found out who you were
they'd probably make you mop the floor
too yeah twice twice just for good
measure that's fantastic